elliot page is living his best life
i'm incredibly grateful the 34 year old
actor shared
this pic of himself on instagram monday
poolside rocking burgundy swim trunks
and a big old smile
just getting to be who i am is such an
incredible experience i feel grateful
for it
and you know i'm in a very fortunate
place in my life
elliott who announced he's transgender
in december
captioned the shirtless shot quote
trans-bibi's first swim trunks hashtag
trans joy
trans is beautiful and he received a ton
of love in the comments
miley cyrus called the look hot while
nina dobrev said you look
amazing and most of all happy and
elliot's umbrella academy co-star justin
cornwell
praised his fit physique writing dude i
see why you crushed me on that workout
it's you know getting out of the shower
and the towels around your waist and
you're looking at yourself in the mirror
and you're just like
there i am last month
elliott cried tears of joy about finally
being comfortable in his
own body during a sit down with oprah
winfrey for the oprah conversation
on apple tv plus it's it's
being able to touch my chest
and
feel comfortable in my body for the
probably the first time
tears of joy he also opened up about his
decision to undergo
top surgery a procedure to remove breast
tissue
and called it life-changing back in
march
elliott posed on the cover of time
magazine and opened up about how the
coronavirus pandemic
led him to come to terms with his gender
identity i had a lot of time
on my own to really focus on things that
i think in so many ways
unconsciously i was avoiding i was
finally able to embrace being
transgender and
letting myself fully become who i am
it's a similar sentiment elliot
previously shared with e.t
when he came out as gay in 2014. i feel
so
happy and i feel so different from how i
felt when i was closeted
and to have experiences where i meet
people
who have been touched in some way
by you know me just getting to be who i
am is
such an incredible experience to get to
share with someone i feel grateful for
it
and he told the mag he's looking forward
to continuing his acting career
now that he's living his truth quote i'm
really excited to act
now that i'm fully who i am in this body
no matter the challenges and difficult
moments of this
nothing amounts to getting to feel how i
feel now
you